In addition to constant-factor approximation algorithms, which we will look at
in more detail soon, we are also going to be talking about advanced algorithms
that are known as polynomial-time approximation schemes. Scary term.
What the idea of a polynomial-time approximation scheme is, it's a sort of more
advanced constant-factor approximation,
so you can think of it as a sort of scale.
The idea behind a polynomial-time approximation scheme is that the running time
actually depends on the quality that you want to get.
With a constant-factor approximation you always get the same guarantee,
say a factor to approximation, and in a polynomial-time approximation scheme,
you can more or less decide what the quality is that you want,
but the better a guarantee you're demanding, with respect to quality,
the more running time you'll have to put into that algorithm.
That's the trade-off here.
But first of all let's look at constant-factor approximation.
We are now going to meet Alice again. Alice, as you know, is working on vertex cover.
So far she has been the most lucky in this course, because she seems to actually
be working on a very well-behaved NP-complete problem.
We also learned that there's good search trees, there's good preprocessing,
and vertex cover was even fixed parameter tractable.
Alice can be quite optomistic about approximating vertex cover,
and actually she has come up with 2 different ideas
of how you could approximate vertex covers.
Here are the 2 possible ideas that she has come up with.
The first algorithm takes this input graph and then looks if some edges are still not covered
in that graph, and if that is the case it takes the uncovered edge and puts both of the endpoints
of that edge into the vertex cover.
Then the algorithm looks again if there is still some uncovered edges, if there are any
of those, then it takes again one and puts both endpoints into the vertex cover
and so on until all edges are covered.
And she calls that algorithm "Take 2," because it always takes 2 endpoints
into the vertex cover each time you go through that loop until you're done.
Here is her second idea, and she calls that idea "Greedy," because what that algorithm does--
It's still the same in the first line here. It looks if some edges are uncovered.
Then what it does is it goes through all of the vertices to determine which vertex could cover
the most edges that are still uncovered.
So which vertex is next to the most edges that have not yet an endpoint in the vertex cover,
and then it puts that vertex in the vertex cover.
It kind of tries to maximize the coverage that it can achieve in each round
that this loop here is run.
So looking at this strategy, so these 2 algorithms, what I would like you to think about
for a moment here is, which of these 2 algorithms should we expect to perform better
in terms of approximation quality?
The one that always takes 2 endpoints, or the one that tries to maximize coverage?